yeah we saw um pretty wild movie last
night that was on shutter wouldn't it
yeah it's uh it's joe bob's last driving
yeah i like that joe bob he's pretty
interesting
jenny's getting me into him it's kind of
like uh
kind of like mst but instead of
commercials he talks
yeah and he just has like information
about the movie yeah he's real
entertaining
i kind of and i like to have breaks in
the movie like commercial breaks yeah
you know so but instead of commercials
you get to hear about the movie so you
know i like it
but it was um what was it called brain
damage brand damage
it's the same guy that made basketball
yeah i didn't see frank and hooker i
don't think you haven't seen frankie no
but i've seen basket case i like that
one too you can tell that
it's made by the same guy yeah frank how
long
have hell and water kind of body horror
type and then water i think that's
yeah kind of body or type stuff but i
think this one was made like an
87 or 88 yeah i think this was 87 that's
not good you know the brain damage came
so i was
uh i was graduating from high school in
that year in brazil
so that's probably why i never seen it
or heard of it
it makes it you know what and here is
something that joe bob told me that i
did not know
but the little uh elmer the little
parasite the brain parasite that like
comes out and like talks and stuff yeah
the voice of him is uh zachary
like the very famous horror host like
probably one of the first horror hosts
if not the first one he's kind of like
the granddaddy of all horror hosts
and um i thought his voice sounded
familiar and then like when they said
but they said that he wasn't credited
because
um it was a non-union movie and he would
have gotten in trouble with the screen
actors guild because he was uh
in the screen actors guild like if he
had been credited in the movie so they
didn't accredit him
but uh he did get paid and stuff so it
reminded me a lot of mr hankey
he said he kind of looked like you
remember mr hankey from
from south park little turds talking
turds kind of like that
except it was this blue alien i guess it
was an alien right did they have really
they didn't no they didn't really say
because there was one point where like
the old guy that had him previously
was kind of going into like the last
couple thousand years of like the
history like where
elmer had been to aylmer i guess his
name is aylmer but um
so i don't know if he was actually an
alien or if he was just like a natural
organism but it's like he um
he goes in your brain and like makes it
like you're tripping out on acid and
makes you feel awesome all the time but
you have to feed him
brains though yeah you have to it kills
people for you
but you have to take it around yeah it
jumps out and kills some people
eats their brains then it goes back in
but it's real reasonable he tries to be
real friendly
he's so cute i kind of love him yeah
but it was it was kind of cool it was
filmed the special effects were actually
pretty good for
for that time especially for it being
basically you know an underground
movie yeah one of those cheapo new york
cheap new york
underground movie kind of like liquid
sky you know it's like along
that level but a lot better
you you expect like um you expect it to
be kind of lovecraftian you know what i
mean with
herbert west and [ __ ] jumping out at any
minute you know
it feels like it feels like jeffrey
combs should be in it
yeah you know we say that about a lot of
movies yeah jeffrey combs should be in
more movies it was you know but it was
that tone
you know what something else that joe
bob told me i think you were in the
bathroom when he gave this little nugget
of information which i had no idea about
but they said you know the last scene
where um
brian the main character who has the
brain parasite
um where where elmer like kills the
girlfriend
like on the subway he's like here's the
thing you can't really
like because for safety and insurance
and blah blah you can't really film on
like the real new york subway usually
like unless you have [ __ ] tons of money
however apparently i don't know if this
is still the case
but apparently the new york subway
system has like
a real subway but it's one that's not
used by the public and it's specifically
for
movies it's like so you can film on the
car
it's like and if you need them if you
need the car to be moving
they have like a driver that they will
hire and they'll like go back and forth
like to brooklyn and [ __ ] like that so
you can like film on a movie so it is
like a real
car it's just not one that's used by the
public and it's not one that you can
like access
from the street it must be an old like
abandoned one and one that was shut down
kinda and they still keep it running you
know yeah you can rent it
and that's what they did for this movie
so that is actually like a real
subway car it's just one that the public
can't use you just i don't know how much
it costs to rent it it couldn't have
been that much back then because the
cars
all you got to do is access the track
yeah there's probably just a track there
and then they divert a car
in onto that track if you um rent it if
you print it yeah yeah
because you know they got all kinds of
cars so i thought that was like
fascinating i was like holy crap i never
would have thought of that because i
guess so many movies are filmed
in new york and are filmed on the subway
system that it's like well might as well
we had this here so we might as well
just like
make some money off it and have people
rent it for movies and whatnot
and not get in the way of like the
public trying to use it but it's pretty
cool
pretty cool flick yeah like i said i
really like little elmer he's like
really cool
it's like you can tell he's really
cheaply made but
it's more um it's a little more
accomplished than basket case and also
there is like a little basket case
uh easter egg in this movie too like
when he's on the subway and he looks
across and like the guy with the basket
i like basket case though i did too but
it's like
super super low yeah like this one's
kind of like a big step up in budget
um and frank and hooker was again
another step up in budget i don't think
i saw that one although i haven't seen
it in many years but i remember really
liking frankenhooker it's actually a lot
of fun
um but yeah so uh we got yeah there's a
whole bunch of other ones that i still
have to watch on there like he even did
he
he even did um that new one that we
reviewed like that uh
that zombie movie one cut of the dead
yeah he did that one last friday yeah
and that's a good movie
yeah so he did that one and he's done
like some jello he did like deep red
and i haven't watched that yet but he's
done like a whole bunch of other like
different uh like see he did society he
did a
castle freak which we reviewed we did
society too
now shutter just has to pick up mst
netflix didn't want it
that's right i really really wish they
would it's like i know it's not horror
but it's
it's kind of sci-fi adjacent and they
usually do show horror movies
on there it doesn't make sense why
netflix didn't want that
yeah that's crazy maybe maybe people
didn't like it maybe didn't get that
many hits
i don't know or they wanted too much
money
yeah i don't know i don't know how it
happened but it's i know because it's
kind of like
i know there's riff tracks and i love
riff tracks and they'll probably just
keep going forever because that business
model is not
super expensive you know what i mean
because they can just make audio tracks
for
movies that already exist and you buy
the movie or stream the movie and pay
for that yourself and then just pay for
the
yeah audio track which was like a
[ __ ] genius idea and like i said it's
not like they're ever going to run out
of movies because they do bad ones good
ones new ones old ones
and there's a lot that are in the public
domain because they always do like
shorts and stuff like that
so it's like they have so much of a
[ __ ] catalog that i could never even
hope to watch them all
but um so they have that but it's kind
of nice like having the show
still around even if it's all different
people um
doing it it's like there's just
something that i like about that format
that's like really comforting
yeah because for for many years like i
would just kind of put that on like
while i was on my exercise bike or while
i was like doing chores around the house
or whatever i just always have mst going
in the background
speaking of shows what uh what what are
we doing this weekend
for show what's the episode going to be
oh you want me to spoil it
oh well i didn't know if you wanted to
tease it i don't know what it is
it's a serial killer okay it's an
old-timey serial killer
all right an old-timey german serial
killer
all right and one of the worst most
gross
dudes ever all right yeah there's some
albert fish level [ __ ] okay
all right so well if you know anything
about true crime you'll probably know
who i'm talking about okay
but uh yeah that's who that's gonna be
all right so another thing i wanted to
say too was that check this out okay so
i think i said yesterday how i was out
on the path the other day and saw like
two
little uh moles like hanging out just on
the side of the thing
this morning i was out there not only
did i see stroller kitty
again who was like this the [ __ ] cat
is so funny the cat sits
exactly the same way in this [ __ ]
stroller she wants to get a stroller
with her two little paws just hanging
out like over the thing just like going
hey you guys look i'm just
and there's squirrels running around and
the cat's just looking going huh yeah
all right um but this morning i'm like
walking and i see
some like two things like up in the
distance
and at first i thought because i was
just seeing them like butt first
so i thought that it was sandhill cranes
which is cool but like i see them all
the time
but then they turned and it was deer it
was two
does yeah and they were just like right
on the side of the path and the weird
thing is that
even though it was only like seven
o'clock this morning the path i guess
because everyone's like you know
been home and they just like like
getting out on the path and everything
because a lot of people live around here
so the path has been like really really
busy like there's always like people
jogging and walking their dogs and you
know riding their bikes and stuff
so it seemed like the the deer were like
hanging out and then
people started walking this way and
people were walking that way and i was
walking this way and i had my camera
going because i said oh i'm gonna take a
picture but they kept like scooting
farther away so i can get a picture
um and it they actually started they
they looked like they were getting like
confused because they're like oh [ __ ]
there's like all these people now what
do we do
and like one of them like went right in
in the path like only about 100
yards in front of me and a guy on a bike
like had to [ __ ] stop because he was
like the
deer was like oh [ __ ] what am i gonna do
and then like went went across and like
jumped into the bushes and then the
other one was like oh [ __ ] and jumped in
the bushes on that side
so i don't know there was a lady like
walking the other way and she got a
picture of them although i don't know
how good it was
because we were just kind of laughing
like that was [ __ ] crazy yeah those
deer sleep out asleep out here on this
lawn
yeah around the uh uh a little pond
yeah because when i look for pookie
sometimes i see the deer eyes looking
back at me
and pookie will be like sitting out
there looking i'm like
look big huge giant kitties with me yes
and when i've had to look when i've had
to look for pookie on that back path
you know back when she used to jump the
fence yeah she did go underneath the
fence
the deer would be out there moving
around deer move at night a lot
yeah they were probably up all night and
getting ready to bed down when you saw
them at seven in the morning they
you know they sleep during the day yeah
i usually see them whenever i see
because i've seen them on the path a few
times it's always like real early in the
morning
and i used to see them a lot like when i
was driving to work yeah well like it's
between
6 7 7 30. i say that you know that
they're up all night that's not always
true
they move at night when the moon is full
and there's good visibility
um it depends on the seasons sometimes
they'll be up during the day too
you know but usually dusk and dawn
that's when you're mostly going to see
them
that's what i usually see them like
really early in the morning they're
either bedding down or getting up
depending on
how you know depending on how the moon
light was although you know what i used
to really see them a lot when i used to
what i lived over here like in orlando
but i worked in daytona
um and i worked the night shift so i was
like driving back um to
orlando at like you know three in the
morning all the time i would see them
along the side of i-4
pretty much every night yeah they're
like right around three in the morning
yeah there's [ __ ] deer all over there
they're almost pests they're just so
many of them
true yeah and they're living in the city
living we're you know we're
this isn't the country anymore this is
the [ __ ] suburbs they're still
the bears are still here it's hilarious
well yeah like i said every now and then
i'll see bears like just trucking across
somebody's yard although it's not as
it's not as weird as you think because
if you head out towards that 7-11 and
you just go three or four miles that's
[ __ ] farmland in country so
it is we're on the outskirts because it
used to be i mean where we live now i
mean used to be
all rural it used to be all like horse
farms pretty much yeah they're even
building a damn freeway off ramp here
and yeah an interchange like only a mile
or two from us i think it is
yeah this used to be i mean there's
still horse farms out here
but you know they're still acreage like
a little bit one two three
four five housing complexes
yeah just like right just like this one
everywhere yeah right here
even like along the path like when we
used to walk along the path
like they built i don't even is it 10
houses 12 houses something like that
they built like a whole thing just like
right there like behind the trees like
right there on the side of the path
with a little gate that goes to it and
everything yeah it's built up now
yeah it's crazy still don't have a gas
station
that is one thing that i really wish
they would build because it's it's a
pain in the ass
to go to like if you go one way from our
house
you know there's like there's a
walgreens there's a mcdonald's there's a
publix there's a big hotel
there's like all kind of restaurants and
[ __ ] like that so it's like right there
but the only gas station is like the
other way and it's like
farther yeah and i really and it's just
we never go that way because there's not
much over there that we need to go to
we don't want to bore them with our
personal problems though about with the
fact that there's no gas station here
it's a painted mess it is it's like they
build so much [ __ ] [ __ ] around here i
can't believe it
i know they're ugly and it's like
they're all like about aesthetics and
everything but it's like i really wish
they would
put like a [ __ ] i wish they would put
a gas station right next to that [ __ ]
daycare that's next
to tear down that nasty old-fashioned
church across the street that looks like
a postdoc the church that looks like a
dmv
it looks like a [ __ ] dmv or post
office it's the ugliest [ __ ] thing
i've ever seen
you need to tear that [ __ ] down i'd
rather have a gas station right there
yeah i feel like that church has
probably been there before all the
houses were there
it's not zoned for architecture it's not
zone four
it's not but you could you could build a
pretty gas station
gas station yeah it's just like a pain
in the ass man it's like i want one
there it's like i want to be able to
like walk over there get some coffee and
[ __ ] like that i can't like [ __ ]
walk all the way down to 7-eleven that's
like [ __ ] five miles
yeah else is new anything
um i don't think so yeah it's kind of
kind of a slow day
it is yeah um hopefully i put up my
witching hour stories today so one of
those was my stories
i think the next couple i'm gonna do
like uh two of my own stories like on
each one because i have some like ideas
about
a theme that i want to do because i have
got a couple messages it's like you know
we like the
you know the classic stories and stuff
but it's like you should put some more
of your stories on there so i was like
okay well i might as well
because you know you can always like
classic stories like anybody can read
those i guess but
because there's other people reading
them but uh so yeah we'll probably wrap
this up for
our thursday so have a good rest of your
day and uh we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow